a wall of flames consuming all before it
the firemen trying to slow its advance a
fighting and losing battle wildfires
have been raging in Australia for months
now
scorching more than 3 million hectares
of land and destroying over 700 homes
their smoke has engulfed Sydney blurring
its iconic skyline but with record
temperatures fanning the flames the
state of New South Wales is preparing
for things to get worse given the
severity of extreme weather conditions
today and also Saturday and for the next
few days on advice of Commissioner
Fitzsimmons New South Wales will be in a
state of emergency from today for the
next seven days scientists blame global
warming for the severity of this year's
fires parched from the searing heat New
South Wales is a tinderbox already
alight
we've got just under 100 fires burning
across New South Wales and half of them
are not contained whilst today is going
to be a very bad day a dangerous day
here in New South Wales the forecast is
that Saturday will be even worse so
we're talking about some very serious
and dangerous conditions over the coming
days with the heat bearing down many
Australians took to the waves to cool
off even as they relax on the beach
the flames are creeping closer ok what's
even more dangerous conditions on the
way let's go straight to Sydney now and
journalist Roger Maynard good morning
Roger a serious situation where you are
what's the latest notes 42 degrees
centigrade on average across Australia
today which is pretty odd by anyone's
standards and as your correspondent
mentioned just now we've got a state of
emergency declared in New South Wales
which will be enforced for at least the
next seven days that state of emergency
will give the authorities greater powers
you get the the the fire authorities in
the place to pilot tests forcibly remove
people from their homes if necessary but
the real
here's the moment to seize
unpredictability of the weather no one
really knows where the next fire is
gonna break out or where the burning
embers from those files will be innocent
by winds to other areas and create more
fires today we've had some really
horrific pictures of fires burning out
of control both north and south Lisa
knee three people three firefighters
have been badly burned in those places
and there are reports that as many as 20
homes have been destroyed Bron Roger
with all this unpredictability how are
people coping especially with the health
threat from smoke we've been seeing the
images in Sydney well not coping very
well particularly because of the smoke
haze that which has blanketed Sydney and
muttered New South Wales for the past
fortnight or so today it was really bad
probably worse than earlier of the week
you could see you know a few hundred
metres if you are lucky and you know
that visibility and that those sort of
conditions are creating big health
hazards here for many people the smoke
and the heat is arguably more serious
than the actual bush fires in fact more
people died in Australia from heat waves
then bush fires or floods put together
and doctors here are advising everyone
to stay indoors if possible what they
have to go outside to wear a face mask
you know Roger the heat wave is is
another climate change alarm bell for
Australia how's the government
responding to calls for it to change
course on its current climate policies
well the certainly a big debate going on
over here about the cause of this which
by crisis many people blame the
government for not taking action but not
addressing climate change and making
moves to reduce the country's reliance
on fossil fuels but others argue that
there's no direct link in climate change
and the drought like conditions and dry
weather of course is nothing new to
Australia we have something going on
here for the past well many many
thousands of years even so the
right-of-center
government here is being savaged for its
lack of action a point highlighted today
by the fact that the prime minister
Scott Morrison
has gone off on an overseas holiday
reputedly two away you note and ignore
the situation while Australia burns and
that clearly hasn't gone down too well
with the electorate Roger Maynard with
the latest for us from Sydney Roger
thanks very much for that